welcome to the show yesterday was day
three out of four of the republican
national convention we're going to look
at pictures we're going to look at clips
i'm going to give you sort of my
thoughts on
uh how i would characterize the themes
of days one two and three so far and
will predict the final night tonight but
i i have to say and i think
some other people in the audience are
feeling this way as well especially
people who have been with me
on the live streams nightly i'm
exhausted from this nonsense
and you the the dnc last week was sort
of tiring because
you know i tend to start work on each
day's show relatively early in the
morning and so when it's 9 to 11 p.m and
sometimes it goes 10 minutes late
and then people want me to keep talking
about what we saw
they're just long days so that's that's
like the normal tiredness but the rnc in
particular
is emotionally exhausting because it's
just
constant lies and delusions and
depravity and diabolical claims and
so on and so forth so i'm very much
looking for it to be over and i think
our vacation in a couple of weeks
is going to be a much needed one but
let's look at what happened yesterday so
the keynote yesterday was vice president
mike pence
and there was a big build-up to mike
pence karen pence his wife spoke earlier
and they had a big crowd and incredibly
if you didn't know a pandemic was going
on
you certainly wouldn't have noticed it
from watching the speech we have a few
different pictures you'll see mike pence
after the speech kind of walking down
and fist-bumping and high-fiving people
nobody's wearing a mask everybody on top
of each other from news reports nobody
who was there was tested for coronavirus
donald trump himself also because he
just can't stay away from
any day of this uh convention uh
showed up and came out at fort mchenry
in baltimore maryland
after mike pence's speech and he was
right up near people
and again you know we're outdoors the
transmission possibility is lower but
you're talking about hundreds of people
here and then
of course mathematically you start to it
becomes more and more likely that
somebody's going to get the virus if
they're hanging around each other
donald trump they're right up on people
and then as you can see
just not a mask in sight maybe somebody
was wearing a mask but from
all the different angles all the
different video and pictures that we
have of the event
it did not appear as though anybody
anybody was wearing a mask
people were sitting relatively close
together it was like there was no
pandemic going on so i tweeted yesterday
how many cases do you think
this event will be ultimately
responsible for
most people thought the number was
certainly more than zero but
it remains to be seen and again it's the
optics it's the optics of pretending and
acting like everything is normal
now in terms of the themes of the three
republican national convention days so
far
day one here's the way i see it
day one was unhinged screaming right
like
upper screaming outrageous
sort of like amphetamine day where you
had don junior out of control
sw eyes almost completely swollen shut
we'll talk about that later he's denied
that the entire thing was
fueled by cocaine you had don junior's
girlfriend kimberly guilfoyle
reminiscent of north korean propaganda
screaming speech
day two i would kind of call downer day
where it was really a very
boring down day capped by melania
trump's very low key
almost unenthusiastic support
of donald trump and indeed if you've
been following what's been going on with
the two of them for the last four years
she may not be enthusiastic about donald
trump getting re-elected
and then day three last night i think
was the dangerous day where you're going
to see
the types of claims that were made not
just by mike pence but by other speakers
were the types of claims that
could certainly move people to real
world violence so let's look at a
couple of different things one cutesy
little idea that has been now
it's just become popular as a trope in
during the rnc
is claiming joe biden and democrats are
going to cancel and
end stuff remember they're going to end
the suburbs was a popular one
here is a senator joni ernst who is
potentially going to be removed from the
senate we can hope
saying that if you elect joe biden he's
going to ban animal agriculture and he's
also going to
eliminate gas-powered vehicles if given
power
they would essentially ban animal
agriculture
and eliminate gas-powered cars now
of course this is not true the truth is
that joe biden does have noam chomsky
agrees
i've looked at it and i don't know how
anyone could come to any other
conclusion joe biden does have
the most progressive climate platform of
any
would-be president if joe biden is
elected that will be the most
progressive climate platform and yes it
has aggressive
goals for phasing out the internal
combustion engine which i
am in favor of it has aggressive goals
for reducing emissions from animal
agriculture but cows aren't going to be
banned stakes aren't going to be banned
and at no time anytime soon are
gas-powered vehicles going to be banned
another speaker going from senator joni
ernst to senator marcia blackburn from
tennessee who is a long-time republican
bomb thrower
she suggests that what democrats want to
do
is to keep coronavirus lockdowns going
so long
that it will force people into a
dependency on the government i guess she
imagines if you keep people locked up
eventually they'll need the government
to bring them food
they'll need the government to bring the
medicine whatever the case may be
a crazy uh uh uh so
sort of exaggeration of uh what
small government people claim the left
wants to do but she said it take a look
if the democrats had their way they
would keep you
locked in your house until you become
dependent on the government
then we also heard as the nepotism
continued
from eric trump's wife lara trump
and one of the funniest themes from her
speech and from others like
a former football player bridges owens
and some others was the idea that
the democratic party are uh
leftist coastal elites
when the entire trump family and most of
their spouses
are actually these coastal elites that
they decry here is lara trump talking
about when she met the trump family
saying they are hard workers and really
down to earth any of those
words never fully weighed on me until i
met my husband
and the trump family any preconceived
notion i had of this family
disappeared immediately they were warm
and caring
they were hard workers and they were
down to earth
they reminded me of my own family they
made me feel like i was home
walking the halls of the trump
organization i saw the same family
environment
i also saw the countless women
executives who thrived there
year after year sort of like opposite
day like that that is the exact opposite
of what the trump family is
they brought in former football coach
lou holtz
who claims that joe biden isn't really
religious
and this is actually really interesting
so let's take a look at the clip
the biden harris ticket is the most
radically pro-abortion campaign in
history
they and other politicians are catholics
in name only and abandon innocent lives
so i've been talking about this a lot
lately including during the streams
because joe biden is the religious
candidate now i don't care about a
candidate's religion
i want religion completely separate from
governance i don't believe an
individual's religion
should play any kind of role in what the
law should be
etc secularism doesn't mean people can't
be religious
in their private lives as a matter of
pride of their own
you know personal conviction but it
should play no role in governance
donald trump is probably not religious
at all donald trump is probably one of
the least religious presidents we've
ever had doesn't make him a good
president i don't care biden's the
religious guy
i'm not religious i prefer biden because
he'd be a better president
but now they are going further because
nominally
everybody knows joe biden is a catholic
they now have to step it up and say
joe biden only claims to be a catholic
he's not really religious which is the
exact type of mind reading
that when we say that person seems
racist
based on their actions the right says
you don't know what's really in their
mind
this is exactly the type of argument
they're making to claim
of course without evidence that trump is
the religious candidate and biden
it really is not because he's lying
about his catholic faith
notice that it's an argument they have
said is a bad argument
when it comes to racist beliefs with
religious beliefs they're comfortable
saying biden's not
actually the religious guy again
bringing up this idea of
law and order and how trump will stop
chaos in the streets take a look at that
last week joe biden didn't say one word
about the violence and chaos engulfing
cities across this country
so let me be clear the violence must
stop
whether in minneapolis portland or
kenosha too many heroes have died
defending our freedom
to see americans strike each other down
we will have
law and order on the streets of this
country for
every american of every race and creed
and color now what is dangerous about
this
is they are pointing to chaos in the
streets now now again protests have
mostly been peaceful
most of the people who have actually
committed violence are
are don't actually appear to be
protesters they appear to be other
things we're going to talk of course
about kyle rittenhouse momentarily but
it's a very strange argument to make
that things are crazy in the streets
right now
after trump's been president for four
years so you should re-elect donald
trump so he can stop the craziness in
the streets that doesn't really
that doesn't make any sense but it
doesn't matter to them and that's what's
so dangerous about this
on coronavirus mike pence talking about
how
um the uh uh on coronavirus
we are actually a country of miracles
and it's not unreasonable to expect a
miracle to help us with coronavirus
which is just
unbelievably wild listen to mike pence
say it here
now last week joe biden said
that no miracle is coming
what joe doesn't seem to understand
is that america is a nation of miracles
and i'm proud to report that we're on
track to have the world's first
safe effective coronavirus vaccine by
the end of this year
so what mike pence doesn't mention there
is that
other countries have already dealt with
coronavirus and they didn't have
miracles they just did the stuff that
our public health officials recommend
mike pence goes into this very strange
rant about
miracles and this is a country of
miracles and we're maybe we're going to
get a miracle
other countries have already dealt with
the virus successfully many countries
they didn't have miracles they had masks
in social distancing and keeping things
closed until it's safe to open them
then again mike pence as an
accomplishment
touting veterans choice as an
accomplishment of the trump
administration
this was an obama law from 2014.
president trump kept his word again
we reformed the va and veterans choice
is now available for every veteran in
america
so it used to be just donald trump who
when asked what are your big
accomplishments he would say well
veterans choice is one
and of course it's not an accomplishment
of his it's a barack obama
accomplishment now mike pence jumping
into that as well
and then mike pence also bragging about
opening up america's schools
and we're not just opening up america
again
we're opening up america's schools
the degree to which he says this like a
badge of honor
confirms to us that the science doesn't
matter
it's just the optics of saying we're
opening
schools despite what the left wants as i
told you yesterday
thousands tens of thousands of cases
already
at a variety of colleges and
universities that have opened problems
in high schools and elementary schools
it's an absolute and total disaster
and then lastly this is sort of the
epitome of what they are running on
mike pence uses the slogan make america
great again but he has to modify it take
a look
and with president donald trump in the
white house for four more years
and with god's help we will make america
great again again
thank you god bless you
right so if you're still trying to make
america great again
after four years it proves you didn't do
it in the four that you got
so now they are sort of trying to take
advantage of coronavirus by saying
we did make america great again then we
had coronavirus
and we're going to make america great
again a second time
the rhetoric yesterday is the type of
rhetoric that i'm worried
is going to lead to violence from
trumpists
if trump loses by a small margin claims
it was rigged
it is the exact type of rhetoric that
will lead to real world violence and we
need to talk now about the polling
because some of my fellow leftists are
getting a little bit
off the rails on this issue one of our
sponsors is privacy.com they're giving
you five dollars when you sign up for
their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a life saver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i
know i won't be charged when the trial
is over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman